gotten a lot of questions about my
college sports career so i'm just going
to give you a brief summary i was
recruited for volleyball but i actually
played three different sports in college
my freshman year i went to ohio northern
it was a small school in ohio i only
played volleyball there i did super well
i ended up getting like freshman of the
year all conference but i really didn't
get along with the team there so i ended
up transferring to a different school so
my sophomore year i transferred to
elmhurst college and i absolutely loved
it i made some of my best friends here
and we got to go to the ncaa tournament
twice my junior year of college i was
asked to join the track team i wasn't
super good they just needed people i
ended up running the 400 and the 800. my
senior year of college i joined the
basketball team when volleyball season
ended i also did a year of grad school
so i could be eligible to play a second
year then i committed to play basketball
in england in this town called
bournemouth this was the school it was
the semi-pro league i was supposed to go
in january but my season got cancelled
and now i just play against juania at
the local gym